方便跟我們看對賬單嗎
對賬單因為我是工作分析師
我比較不方便
那我是可以稍微給你看一下成交紀錄
你可以看到真的有成交 對
哇 真的個十百千萬
哇 真的有千萬
哲哲真的沒騙人
先前趁臺股跌破四萬點
砸一億元 買0050
沒想到風神
更在直播節目上舉杯慶祝
然後再捐我第三臺的救護車
堅持長暴 想再創奇蹟 回顧
哲哲七月二十九號分別以每股九十三點四五
元買進六百零一張 九十三點二元
買進四百九十九張 合計一千一百張
零零五零 總投入資金約一億元
平均持股成本約九十三點三三元
隨著七月三十一號零零五零飆漲停
到一百零二點八五元 賬面獲利大賺千萬
但為何不乾脆買臺積電呢
臺積電理論上一二十年來都會好
但還是有萬億 那有萬億的時候
大家就會發現到那臺灣五十
還是有不錯的分散風險的功能
然而臺股是否還會繼續漲
郭哲榮認為股市中長期上上
其實算一算七月三十一號
臺股狂噴超過三千點
成交量八千三百三十七億元
三大法人買超臺股
八百四十六點七六億元
外資少六百七十五億元
更創下歷史第十大
有一點套利跟利用所謂的
期貨來做一些避險
不過他今天的現貨買超前十年
大部分都是主被動的
ETA股比較多
三十八檔千金股 三十一檔漲停
股王信華亮紅燈 大漲一千三百二十元
漲幅百分之十 成為漲點王
股後川湖也漲停 大漲七百一十元
漲幅百分之九點九四
臺股行情是否能再創新紀錄 市場關注
聽不懂 羅氏彭劉軒 臺北報導